whereas the King answered the
Declaration of Independence did you know
that he gave an address from the throne
and he gave an answer caused it this
answer this address from throne he
caused it to be distributed across the
lines at the siege of Boston and he
basically said in there I was born to be
the King here and you were born to be
the subjects and I am required to look
after you and be good to you and take
care of you and to do what's in your
interest what's good for you but you are
required to do what I say and he thought
that that would turn the whole thing
around and at the moment that he
distributed this thing across the lines
to the Continental Army
it was melting away because their their
enlistments were up and they read that
thing and they went what what he thinks
we're gonna where's that right the
King's idea is that I was born with an
obligation and you were born with an
obligation we both have to do our thing
and we're born that way and the
difference a dependence denies that it
says we're all born equal equal in that
sense that I named right we're not dogs
until the dog started talking so that's
what they say and if it's like that then
you get to be our King if we say so
there's a really great document that
we're not reading in this course but I
encourage everyone to read it in our
Constitution Reader is written by Thomas
Jefferson who of course was a very
powerful writer earth-shaking Lee
powerful writer wrote the deck for some
independence and it's called a summary
view of the rights of British North
America and in there he goes on and on
and on and he explains you get to be the
king if we say so you have to do what we
say in the last paragraph which I'll
paraphrase he says that let those
flattered who fear it is not an American
art
your counselors are partisans not drawn
from us right so he's telling the King
what for you know and it gives rise soon
you know the flag with the snake that
says don't tread on me we have a right
we are born the same as you you get your
carriage since you got it already it's
just that that you don't get to tell us
what to do from it consent is born in
equality in that way right and and just
you just have to remember that we
Americans we just breathe that from
birth we get that with Mother's Milk
you know that's what we think we think
we're born equal